you know when i'm holding him and
cuddling him and he smiles back i mean
what are you going to do you have to try
harder and you have to give it
everything you can nbc news is richard
engel's son henry has died following a
long battle with a rare medical
condition he was six years old he is
happy he'll give you a little smile he's
such a good boy the tv personality
shared the news on twitter writing our
beloved son henry passed away he had the
softest blue eyes an easy smile and a
contagious giggle we always surrounded
him with love and he returned it and so
much more where do you guys find your
strength like i'm looking at two people
and i know that you you i can see how
strong you are where's it come from
from henry yeah i mean you can't um not
get up in the morning you just have to
get up and go and do it and
take care of him and he's raring to go
hoda kotb shared her condolences in a
tweet oh richard i'm so so so sorry my
heart aches for you and your family we
love you piers morgan also chimed in
writing how incredibly sad my deepest
condolences to you and all your family
it's been a years-long medical journey
for richard and his family back in 2018
he and his wife mary opened up about
early signs of henry's condition when
henry was born just over two years ago
he made our life complete the sweetest
happiest boy but almost right away
something didn't seem quite right the
problem was henry wasn't really
progressing he wasn't sitting up when he
should he wasn't
clapping his hands when he showed her we
went to every
doctor we could find following many
tests the doctor found henry had rett
syndrome a rare genetic neurological and
developmental disorder that affects the
way the brain develops it's rare in boys
and untreatable doctors have told us
henry will likely never walk
talk dress himself or have the mental
capacity beyond a toddler and that
health problems are likely coming as
well
kids with this mutation tend to have
epilepsy or seizures of some kind
no matter what's coming we want henry to
know he's loved despite the struggles
richard felt compelled to share their
experience to help others it's not a
story that anybody wants to to tell it
was very difficult for us but we wanted
to raise awareness
to make other families with special
needs children children who are
challenging know that they're not alone
it can feel very lonely while his son
was in treatment researchers were hard
at work on advancing a cure for the
disease henry's mutation is unique in
the world
but it
it because it's unique is what makes it
so valuable sometimes from the rarest
thing you can learn the most and
following henry's death richard reveals
that his little boy's legacy will
someday help others quote researchers
are making amazing progress using henry
cells to help cure rhett's syndrome so
others don't have to endure this
terrible disease
[Music]